[Music]
good morning and welcome to the second
day of net and today I'm excited to
announce that we're adding three more
regions to the test I hope you like live
demos because this is the first of four
live GCP demos you're going to see in
the keynote today and I couldn't be more
excited have spanner be the first one
starting today a TCP VM will come with
up to 64 cords and four hundred sixteen
gigabytes of memory
first I'd like to congratulate Google
under the absolute first to have cloud
services on our next-generation Xeon
processor skylake for one or three year
commitment you receive a discount for up
of up to 57% billed monthly no upfront
payment you can add a GPU to any VM
configuration and start it up in under a
minute
much faster than our competitor within a
matter of minutes you're able to mix the
CPUs GPUs high GPU ratios memory close
to the processor the way we need for
particular algorithms to work in a very
good way so this is a big advantage that
we get out of Google but I would say
another advantage is also state himself
I think Google should be very proud of
having someone like this who is all
right yeah right that's Kate I reckon
from the record that was not in the
script
we put a security tip on all our new
machines to serve as the basis of trust
for that machines identity so this is a
custom chip designed by Google so we
know exactly what it does and it helps
us protect servers against tampering
even at the BIOS level the chip in fact
is so small that I'm actually wearing
one on my earring here we're announcing
several new security features that we're
adding to TCP NT Suites data loss
prevention DLP makes it easy when he
ends the chat we will use data loss
prevention to identify and redact
sensitive information this isn't just
dumb OCR you'll notice it didn't blot
out the expiration date or the name
because we told the API that the only
information we wanted to eliminate was
credit card numbers next clouds came out
management service is now generally
available we also add a tool that lets
you safely access that secured content
the first one is the identity of where a
proxy and last but not least security
key enforcement is now available it's
really important for us that for
developers and windows developers that
we meet them exactly where they are we
want to be a great wing of clapham
perhaps the best Windows platform today
we're announcing the general
availability of sequel server Enterprise
and that actually includes support for
high availability as well as clustering
also a beta of net and that'll be
available in both App Engine and
container engine and to help people on
this journey we're announcing a new
Windows Partner Program
so now Linux or Windows my sequel Oracle
or sequel server and as of today also a
beta of manage Postgres we recently
added right from the cloud console the
ability to migrate a virtual machine to
GCP and this is more than transcoding an
offline image it's actually the live
migration of a running server to GTP so
what's the best test for moving to a
cloud with minimal friction probably be
able to do that with zero downtime so
here
welcome to introduce Jack Constantine
from lush to tell us about their journey
in the actual migration was from
December the 1st until December the 22nd
so it's not just you know a little bit
business-critical we're talking peak
trade time yes it was a huge deal we
made 17 websites from all over the world
with customer data with all the data
product data obviously one on the back
up and stable back in 2008 Google App
Engine was really it was pioneering
service and was ahead of its time so out
of the box we now support seven popular
languages Java Ruby go PHP Python C
sharp and node or you can now for the
first time bring your own runtime bring
your own framework to App Engine
flexible environments as long as it runs
in that docker container it now runs on
App Engine server this is a really
important concept and today we're
announcing the beta of our newest
service offering cloud functions we've
also integrated the
functions that we just talked about with
firebase and so that allows firebase
developers to extend their back-end
logic in crazy ways and today we're
actually making firebase even more
powerful so now you can access any GCS
bucket anywhere in the world right from
firebase we integrated cloud storage
into the firebase SDKs so great
companies use data to react faster to
the market build novel new products and
even change culturally how they work
we're now saying the Google bigquery
data transfer service and what that does
is it automates the transfer of data
from SAS applications into bigquery but
it doesn't on a schedule manage basis
that's why today we're introducing cloud
data prep and data prep is this
intelligent data service that allows you
to visually explore and clean your data
so that it can be integrated into a
bigquery environment as Appaji we know a
thing or two about AP is we process
billions of API calls in our cloud you
process billions of API calls using our
technology in your cloud everybody is
choosing cloud
[Music]
[Applause]